let's talk a little bit about what  exactly a commit is now we talked about  a commit being a snapshot and that's  exactly what it is a commit is  represented by a forty character sha-1  hash and I wrote a couple little  shortened versions over here but in that  forty characters there's a lot more than  just numbers and letters there is a blob  of the changes so blobs represent files  so you may change in say two index.html  git stores a blob of that file which is  a reduced version of that code in a very  lightweight way it also includes some  metadata if that means who made the  commitment what time did they make the  commit and what's the parent commit you  know what's the commit that was made  right before this on this working branch  all of that information is stored and  compressed in that forty characters  sha-1 hash which means that commit ID is  very very important